well I'm joined Now by my Pat Paul
Burrell of course famous Royal Butler uh
Katie nickel one of the top royal uh
experts I suppose you are aren't you and
Paula Ron Adrian
um of course is here as well so let me
start with Paul Burrell Paul
we've talked a bit about this haven't we
um about this fracturing between William
and Harry
's now gone on television and called his
brother William a bully that bullied him
out of the country
I've made a number of other allegations
yeah is that a liar he had to go at the
queen and everything when you watch it I
mean my jaw was dropping that he was
literally taking them all down one by
one what was your jaw doing
I was well I saw six hours of it and I
was very saddened by all of it because I
realized that there's no way back now
for Harry he's abandoned his family he's
abandoned his duty and he's abandoned
his country and he he's disrespected his
grandmother's Legacy which is the
Commonwealth of countries which he
upheld all her all her uh through her
lifetime and you know you can't say
these things about your family and get
away with it and I don't think that
he'll ever be welcomed back here again I
think the British public will have
something to say about that and there
are certain things that came out in in
this interview which I totally didn't
agree with at all I mean he said that he
couldn't get to his grandmother he lived
literally a few hundred yards away from
her back door at Windsor Castle at
Frogmore Cottages he could have walked
up the hill gone through that door and
gone into his grandmother's sitting room
at any time and said granny I've got a
problem the Queen's door was always open
it doesn't matter about what the
courtiers say the queen would say I'm
your grandmother Harry I love you you
can come and talk to me if you have a
problem so Harry you're trying to pull
the wool over our eyes I know better
than that and the meeting at Sandringham
yes you did attend that and in that
meeting apparently Harry said to his
grandmother I'd like to stay in the
royal family and wear my uniforms and
have my Army contacts and then go back
to America and do my commercial
campaigns and the queen quite rightly
said Harry you can't have one foot in
the camper one foot out because that's
not fair to the rest of the royal family
who can't do these commercial deals who
who just do their Duty for the country
so you can't have your cake and eat it
and quite rightly the Queen the queen
herself said no yeah and so Harry went
and so he had a digger her in the
Netflix series whilst knowing that yes
she'd recently lost Prince Philip and
that she herself was in very ill health
and has now died sadly you know the
timing of all this above nothing else is
so reprehensible Paula Ron Adrian look
you've always defended but Paul just
hang on a sec yes I always defended
Harry yeah I'll come back to you ball
I'm talking to Paula just quickly about
this you've always defended them
surely when you watch that latest stuff
today
watching anybody take down their brother
their father their grandmother
on television
it's not a good thing
it's not a good thing but I have always
said to you peers that this is only
going to get worse unless we stop and
start listening what you are witnessing
are people who believe that they have
been treated badly whether you believe
them or not whether you want to shout at
them or not whether you want to deny
them or not whether we want whether you
want us to listen to 12 minutes of you
telling us how awful they are is you I
think they are awful but that may well
be your opinion but you're here to give
me yours right that's different yeah and
what is happening so I mean you're
entitled to say whatever you want well
of course and so are they and so are
they yes and that is what they are doing
that is what they feel they have been
they can say what they like they do when
they do what they do fine but when they
do what they do we are entitled in this
country when our country is put under
attack like this and branded a racist
country by these two
with a racist royal family of the head
of it we are entitled to defend what
this country stands to know about the
Institute that is the royal family we've
seen what happens when somebody calls
out a member of the Royals royal
household and says that they are racist
what happens to them well they have to
stop working they have to clean who is
racist uh well we know that there was
the incident with Miss with Lady hussy
she was removed from office within 24.
we won't forget she was removed the
moment because she was made accountable
of what who was racist to Megan and
Harry it could have been lady hussy you
don't know dear it could have been they
said it was a member of the family it
could have been somebody else and so
what we're doing we're told is could be
any of them so they're all all Smith by
association and as I've said we can keep
shouting but the fact is they are
hurting and we are witnessing them
you say they're counting their money
yeah I mean look you're not criticizing
Mike Tyndall for being on I'm a
celebrity are you or doing adverts with
Amazon or dominoes or whoever it is he's
doing is not a paid up member of the
royal family he doesn't get anything
from the from the taxpayers not now
what they've done earn money no no hang
on they've given up Royal Duty and
they've left the country in the family
but what they haven't given up is the
Royal titles which now make them all the
money because what I was just about to
say the point of Royal titles they
listen they are entitled to have their
opinion if they absolutely
hate The Establishment they hate well
they've left Britain right they've stood
down as working Royals and I think there
is a real issue with them holding on to
those titles very clear to see from
everything that we've seen in Netflix
that without that Royal calling card
there is nothing that no one is no one
is actually interested in what they have
to say about anything else
if they hate the institution so much if
if it's racist and bigoted and
everything else then do what they
actually said and this was new because
this was one of the new things that did
come out of today they offered to return
those titles if their version of a half
in half out monarchy didn't work so they
put that off on the table if they have a
shred of dignity left put that offer
back on the table and follow through why
would you want to be in a racist
institution so why would why would a
black police officer want to be part of
of the police Metropolitan Police why
would a black female fire often want to
be a part of the London Fire why do they
want to be able to do it you do it
they're all family because they love it
you do it because you love they don't
love the royal family
you're talking about his dad he's
talking about his brother of course they
are in pain
causing pain they're inflicting Pains
come on there's more they're the ones
doing all the abuses victim blaming this
is a classic when you blame it back and
look at what's happening they're not
victims what you are hearing and what
I'm hearing isn't salute tsunami of
denial denial denial and anything that
comes out of their mouth I don't believe
it so I want to hear you say that
absolutely everything that has come out
of Harry and Megan's mouth is a lie I
think a lot of it is actually yeah
if there is some if there is some truth
in what they've got to say should we not
be worried
today which I thought completely sum
them up
there was Tyler Perry for some random
reason he'd never met and decides to
give him his Mansion so they're living
in this vast Mansion during the covert
pandemic which you think they might feel
lucky about but no no they're moaning
away about that too and Tyler Perry uh
is talking over footage and saying
they've been abused by their status in
the royal family and the footage shows a
sneaky Paparazzi craning down from a
rooftop taking pictures of them with
their child only it wasn't a Paparazzi
it was a royal photographer who had been
accredited and approved by them to take
those pictures on an official tour so it
wasn't what it seemed it was a lie
they're the producers of this series
they know it's a lie and they put it in
there so that people fall for this
claptrap rather like we saw the vast
Army of Paparazzi aiming at some event
but it wasn't it was a Harry Potter
Premiere they weren't even there it was
five years before he met Meghan Markle
all of it is smoke and mirrors and on
the really incendiary stuff no evidence
who is this person at the palace that
said to Meghan Markle I don't care that
you're feeling suicidal you don't get
any help why didn't Harry get her the
help if she was genuinely suicidal who
is the racist in the palace they still
won't tell us these are serious
allegations causing serious damage to
our royal family and this country's
reputation and it's not good enough that
they keep going on television spray
gunning everybody again and they don't
give us the actual facts
have been incredibly Brave take him on
an Institute
to take them down and you should get
around two institutions that I'm afraid
they're trying to take down and this is
this is a blatant attempt to take down
but they won't succeed and I think the
Royal Family's dignity in maintaining
its silence and that show togetherness
tonight is actually what people want
people I think people are just switching
off people to believe that the royal
family are keeping a dignified silence
we know that that's not true
[Music]
the articles in the newspapers it always
references the source
it's always a source well we're well
where is this sauce
I've got to leave it there final
question just to pull before we let you
go Paul you've been around the royal
family a very long time what will the
royal family be feeling about all this
they'll be appalled by all of this
washing dirty laundry in public it's not
their scene and they will close ranks
they will hold it together with dignity
and you're quite right that's what we
expect them to do
um don't attack Kate and William because
they are our future king and queen right
cases never put a foot wrong don't
attack her she's she's the jewel in our
Crown right now and she deserves our
respect and admiration and had
unbelievable criticism early on actually
which everyone can be interested you
don't see any of that in the series it's
all just about negative for Megan
positive for okay total lies absolute
lies anyway thank you fasten your seat
belts though
400 Pages
this never stops right thank you Katie
good to see you thank you Paula always
good to hear the other view uh I don't
agree with it but I respect your right
to have it I hope I miss it well still
to come tonight and look at the division
it causes here as well they've launched
a load of divisions